strongly disagree with this decision of
the of the Supreme Court I have art most
respect for our judiciary I don't think
this was the right decision I think that
the frogadier of prorogation has been
used for four centuries without this
kind of without this kind of challenge
it's perfectly usual to have a Queen's
Speech that's what we want to do but
more importantly let's be no doubt there
are a lot of people who want to
frustrate Rexie there are a lot of
people who basically want to stop this
country coming out of the EU and we have
a parliament that is unable to be brodes
unable to doesn't want to have an
election and I think it's time we took
things forward
you say you weren't extend brexit but
how do you avoid doing that now you've
run out of options well on the country
the the law as the law currently stands
the UK leaves the EU on October the 31st
come what may but the interesting thing
that will the exciting thing for us now
is to is to get a good deal and that's
what we're working on and we always have
you John
it's not made much easier by this kind
of stuff in in in Parliament or in in
the courses it would obviously getting a
deal it is not made much easier against
this background but we're gonna get on
doing good just finally you say as the
law stands we leave on October the 31st
that's not true is it as the law stands
we cannot leave with no deal on October
the 31st without the permission of
Parliament as the law stands we leave on
October the 31st and I'm very hopeful
that we will get a deal and I think what
the people of the country want is to see
parliamentarians coming together working
on in the national interest to get this
thing done and that's what we're gonna
do Prime Minister thank you